I'm Dermot this is Julia and we're doing
the wired auto-complete yep I don't
understand the game Julia Roberts is
just right she's five I'm pretty tall no
you we're tall is Julia Roberts the
highest-paid actress in the history oh
it's a long question in the history of
all humankind
are you English no but she's very proper
and I like T she's from Georgia God make
it sound like a slight so George
well Smyrna Georgia yeah it's Julia
Roberts related to Kyra Sedgwick oh we
played sisters what was that it
something to talk about
mmm lots of hafstrom film yeah so my
parents were portrayed by Robert Duvall
and Jenna Rowland's how cool is that
great actors yeah Wow didn't see it what
do you do with your free time
I don't watch your movies oh I didn't
see a pretty woman until 2000 know in
the top 2005 I never saw not like 1938
yeah you're late today I mean I already
knew you and I saw and I thought it was
terrific filming it Vic I didn't realize
we've learned so much about each other
today what does Dermot Mulroney look
like I'm just kind of framing your face
with this that's what he looks like you
know I'm playing on a TV show right now
station 19 and the young actor Alberto
lights up it looked
like me huh I'll watch that in 12 years
what TV show is Dermot Mulroney in
station 19 yeah one of them also
Arrested Development new girl old story
homecoming someone give me a razor I
need to shave my what is Dermot Mulroney
'he's real name well it's interesting it
is Alberto Frank yes exactly
what is Dermot Mulroney worth he's
priceless it's true who is Julia Roberts
mother and father Betty and Walter
Roberts awesome Betty I never knew
Walter yeah it was a good friend of mine
who was Julia Roberts best friend me a
girl it would be Paige Samson who I grew
up with who does Julia Roberts look like
Emma Roberts yeah that's true Oh Juliet
binos and I always think I see myself in
magazines and it turns out I flutter
myself look at this Jennifer Garner oh
she's beautiful too
so is Julia Roberts baby daddy well that
would mean I have a baby with someone
who I'm not married to na not applicable
ona is Dermot Mulroney is Darrin Lonnie
I am is you is or is you ain't is it
Dylan McDermott or Dermot Mulroney
[Music]
Mulroney yeah is Dermot Mulroney
ready yes barely single no is Dermot
Mulroney Irish Dermot Mulroney no I mean
the name is deeply Irish Dermot Patrick
Mulroney can't get more Irish than that
people I mean I guess you could actually
clog the Mulroney's have been here for a
hundred and fifty years so what's Julia
Roberts without doing now
not very well no I didn't say out what
does Julia Roberts look like now
maintaining her agreement with America
always be young and beautiful it's not
that hard
well yeah you're more than it with the
entire country more than living up to
your end of the bargain anything what is
Julia Roberts middle a oh I know yeah
tell him it's Fiona yep
what was Julia Roberts first movie
satisfaction that's the answer that's
the name of the movie not how I'm
feeling about that about getting that
answer right
what does Julia Roberts hate everybody
she has a great ass okay I gotta tell
you I'm no Julia for a long time she
won't eat onions though no ever yeah
don't invite me over for onion soup that
would be bad I'm just amazed that it's
even spelled right let me explain
something you know they upgraded my
phone it won't believe the word it's
like the Google office but there weren't
Dermott to dr mot what is it try to turn
it into to the team huh the EEM you have
to talk to someone smarter than me about
like it's got to go to the top of Google
and six for real it's a word who is who
is who is Adi
he's the everyman he's the man you go to
for advice for good company who's
[Laughter]
playing
I played Gavin I learned this when they
released friends on Netflix because I
was suddenly being shouted at on this
street hey Gavin Gavin I could do that
and use out of spell Kevin you know why
because it's a name Gavin Gavin
shouldn't be a very popular name but it
is a name and Google knows it Dermot is
a name and Google doesn't know who is
Dermot Mulroney father
Michel Mulroney is my dad he's awesome
your dad yeah he's doing great
who does Dermot Mulroney god they can
all be so misconstrue so easily look
look like jean-paul Belmondo looky who
is terment Mulroney's wife prema prema
prema mulroney how julia roberts can I
meet Julia Roberts how can I meet Julia
Roberts
telling you that nice young man came
over from Philippines and you know Kenny
Kenny you were so common even Indonesia
D'Arnot how many languages can Julie
Roberts speak 3 really what are they I
can't share that Oh understood one of
them might be pig latin right oh one how
does Julia Roberts curl her hair I'm
naturally curly hair Sally and Charlie
Brown how old
Julia Roberts mystic pizza I think I
turned 20 on that movie do you it's 30
years this weekend somebody just told me
that incredibly here's to you there how
does Julia Roberts tan shape eat well
eat well happiness fulfillment no onions
no American very fattening how to
pronounce Dermot Mulroney
that's how so right when it said right
Dermot Mulroney how tall is Dermot
Mulroney five cents to five eleven and a
half and 9/11 how old is Dermot Mulroney
Dermot Mulroney 's birthday is in just
over a week because he comes right after
mine it will be only slightly older than
me how did Dermot Mulroney get his scar
I fell down when I was three and a half
years old I was carrying a rabbit dish
and it was a big night because I got to
feed the rabbits deer rabbits - no no
the rabbits are in the hutch in the
backyard and that was going into your
mother enjoyed that moment boys waiting
for
memory was bloody my first memory is
bloody and knocked my front teeth that
you know you're done yeah my baby
your baby's wife it's funny you should
ask she's 23 and 3/4 can Julia Roberts
sing like an angel can Julia Roberts win
an Oscar yeah
with Julia Roberts this one know what
you can did you Roberts die no that's
not on their lips Julia Roberts
character are you know I think it means
well yeah
I'm rubber you're glue questions for you
okay we're Julia Roberts born
we're Julia Roberts born I was born in a
little town called Smyrna Smyrna Georgia
where does Julie Roberts go in Eat Pray
Love where do you go where does that
take place I think some of it was in
Tuscany I saw he pray love no he didn't
I was in Rome well you know did you doze
off during the eat part
earlier like a car driving to a vineyard
I remember that I think you're thinking
of a Diane Lane movie maybe oh yeah yeah
I think you are good go to Julia Roberts
look look
maybe not Elaine I think we're having
some breakthroughs here where is Dermot
Mulroney from Oh Chicago huh I was born
in Alexandria Virginia I was born in
Washington DC I was out in Tuscany does
Dermot Mulroney sing he is an exemplary
musician thank you
how many instruments can you play 995
dermot mulroney careful what you wish
for
well oh that time of a film I was like
that's kind of a foreboding thing
careful what you wish for trying to get
a message that's how it came across to
me no it's a film that probably didn't
get
attention let's not give it anymore and
so they couldn't get their hands on it
Roadhouse yeah it was were you really
were you Patrick Swayze I was was Dermot
Mulroney in young guns yeah and bad
girls Julian just saw bad girls
yesterday one of mine not the other
night yes dürdane how did I look yeah
well gorgeous and like someone had iron
is because we're so young we're never
gonna be a younger than we are right I'm
aging by the moment I'm watching it